[Music]
hello everyone I'm Alicia Malone welcome
to Fandango in the movie guide the show
that has been called energetic by the
New York Times and it's true I do get
very excited when I talk about indie
films and one that I'm really really
excited about comes out this weekend
it's called the Florida project directed
by Sean Baker okay
I warned it one drip in you're out this
is set in Florida at a series of motels
just outside the happiest place on earth
Disney World but it's all about the
invisible homeless who live in these
motels the story is told through a
six-year-olds eyes so you get to skip
along with her as she goes through her
own Magic Kingdom and she has little
scams to get money she doesn't really
have any concept that they're living in
poverty and through her eyes you slowly
pieced together exactly what's happening
in her world how does a mother moaning
you it sounds overly sentimental but it
absolutely is not it's full of vibrant
energy great performances all around
from young Brooklyn Prince right up to
Willem Dafoe Shaun Baker was the
director behind tangerine and take-out
and he's so good at telling these
stories about people that we might pass
every day but we don't give a second
thought to emotional heartbreaking and
full of i popping Cola I highly
recommend the Florida Project out this
weekend
[Music]
love you too another vibrant film out in
theaters this weekend in a very
different way roll in cell block 99
starring Vince Vaughn but it's not like
any Vince Vaughn film you have ever seen
it's directed by s Craig Saleh who did
bone tomahawk and it is a violent macho
film that feels like it was ripped out
of the 70s grindhouse theatres Vince
Vaughn plays an aggressive man who is
actually trying to do the right thing
for his pregnant wife he wants to
provide for them but unfortunately that
leads him into incarceration which in
turn leads him into some very violent
gory dark situations it is two hours and
12 minutes long and it does feel just a
little bit long but Vince Vaughn is
absolutely incredible
he plays his role with such conviction
here he takes that kind of physicality
from his comedy films and gives it a
huge twist taking it into a very dark
place it's not for the faint-hearted but
it is a genre film that celebrates the
genre role in cellblock 99 is out in
limited theaters from this weekend I'm
going to tell you anything you want to
hear and prison will give me plenty of
time to look at guys I don't like
[Music]
my third recommendation for a film to
watch in theaters this weekend is
walking out directed by Andrew and Alex
Smith this is a survival story starring
Matt Bomer as a father who takes his
young son out hunting when they
encounter a bear does have shades of the
revenant but really it's more about
family relationships and the idea of
masculinity it's also a very very
engaging thriller and it has the
beautiful backdrop of the mountains
which go from being or inspiring to
terrifying and very isolating you can
just keep going
yeah most of the movie it is just these
two characters they're father and son
Matt Bomer and Josh Wiggins but there
are great cameos from Bill Pullman and
Lily Gladstone not a whole lot of
dialogue it's mainly about the emotion
that you see on their faces
I really enjoyed walking out although I
never want to go into the mountains near
any bears you can see walking out in
theaters from this weekend
don't you worry those are my
recommendations in theaters you can see
the florida project brawl in cellblock
99 walking out and you can catch me
Alicia Malone on this show next week or
on Twitter anytime a deletion alone and
in the comments below if you're watching
on YouTube I want to know from you who
is your favorite comedic actor turned
dramatic actor do you like Ben Stiller
when he's in dramas do you like Adam
Sandler when he's in dramas or even
Vince Vaughn I want to hear from you and
I'll see you soon bye
[Music]